En 1931, paraissait dans la revue Monatshefte für Mathematik,
un article au titre apparemment incompréhensible,
écrit par un jeune logicien qui n'avait
seulement que 25 ans, Kurt Gödel.
Cet article contenait 2 théorèmes
qui allaient révolutionner notre compréhension
du fondement des mathématiques.
Les théorèmes d'incomplétude.
♪ [Générique] ♪
La première fois que j'ai entendu parler
du premier théorème d'incomplétude de Gödel
c'était en cours de philo, en terminale.
Le prof nous avait expliqué que ce théorème affirmait qu'en mathématiques ,
il existerait toujours des vérités qui sont indémontrables
Alors j'vous avoue que sur le coup ca m'avait un peu choqué.
Qu'est ce que ca veut dire exactement qu'il existe des choses qui sont vraies et indémontrables?
Et comment affirmer ça, ça peut être un théorème?
Eh bien, on va essayer de le comprendre ensemble.
En mathématiques, on passe son temps à faire des démonstrations
et d'ailleurs c'est assez fréquent que les exos de maths qu'on fait au lycée ou bien plus tard
soient posés sous cette forme.
Par exemple "démontrez moi que la somme des angles d'un triangles fait 180° "
Ou bien "'démontrez moi le théorème de Pytagore"
Ou "démontrez moi que racine de deux ne peut pas s'écrire comme une fraction"  etc
L'idée qui traine derrière, c'est que si on arrive à démontrer quelque chose, c'est que ce quelque chose doit être vrai.
Par exemple le théorème de Pytagore, on sait le démontrer
et il est vrai, il fonctionne. Il n'y a pas un seul triangle rectangle dans lequel  il ne marcherait pas.
C'est ça l'interêt de faire des démonstrations, c'est pour être certain que quelque chose est vrai.
Inversement si quelque chose est vrai, on se dit qu'il doit être démontrable.
Ca veut pas dire qu'on a déjà trouvé la démonstration, mais on est sûr qu'il doit en exister une quelque part.
Donc quand on fait des mathématiques à notre niveau, "vrai" et "démontrable", on fait comme si c'était la même chose
Ce qui est vrai est démontrable, ce qui est démontrable est vrai.
Eh bien pour comprendre l'objet des travaux de Gödel, il faut commencer par réaliser que non:
vrai et démontrable, ça n'est pas la même chose.
Pour ça il faut commencer par se demander, qu'est ce que c’est une démonstration?
Alors c'est pas toujours explicite quand on fait des raisonnements mathématiques,
mais les démonstrations en maths utilisent ce qu'on appelle la méthode axiomatique
Quand on fait des raisonnements mathématiques, au départ on se donne un nombre restreint d'affirmation
que l'on va admettre sans démonstration. On appelle ca les axiomes.
Et dans une démonstration, on combine ces axiomes en utilisant les règles de la logique
dans le but de créer de nouvelles affirmations
et ces nouvelles affirmations, on les appelle des théorèmes.
Alors on va commencer par prendre un exemple simpliste. Imaginons que je me donne 3 axiomes:
Axiome 1: Tous les êtres humains sont mortels.
Axiome 2: Tous les hommes sont des être humains.
Et, Axiome 3: Socrate est un homme.
Alors vous voyez qu'en combinant les axiomes 1 et 2, et en combinant les axiomes de la logique,
je peux déduire l'affirmation suivante: tous les hommes sont mortels.
Cette affirmation, c'est un théorème,  c'est à dire qu'on l'a déduit des axiomes,  on en a fait une démonstration.
Mais maintenant, en combinant ce théorème avec l'axiome 3,
je peux déduire un nouveau théorème qui dit "Socrate est mortel".
Cet exemple est ultra-basique donc on peut pas aller beaucoup plus loin, mais vous voyez l'idée:
on part d'axiomes, on construit des théorèmes,
et on peut s'appuyer sur ces théorème pour construire encore de nouveaux théorèmes, et ainsi de-suite.
On peut prendre un analogie illustrée.
Les axiomes ce sont comme des briques de légo de base
qu'on aurait le droit d'utiliser autant de fois qu'on veut, et de combiner entre elles.
Et quand on combine des briques de base, bah on obtient des structures plus complexes, les théorèmes.
Qu'on peut, à leur tour, utiliser et combiner pour construire des structures de plus en plus riches.
La beauté de la méthode axiomatique, c'est que, comme avec les légo,
en partant d'un nombre restreint d'axiomes, on peut construire tout un tas de théorèmes.
Mais vous voyez que ca dépend évidement du système d'axiomes qu'on se donne au départ.
Mon exemple avec les trois axiomes de Socrate ne nous a pas emmené très loin.
Quand on veut faire des mathématiques, il faut bien choisir son système d'axiomes,
et il existe plusieurs possibilités suivant le domaine dans lequel on veut travailler.
Si vous voulez faire de la géométrie dans le plan ,vous pouvez utiliser les axiomes d'Euclide.
Je vous les liste ici.
Si vous voulez faire plutôt de l'arithmétique des nombres entiers,
il est possible d'utiliser les axiomes dit de Péano
En voici quelques un:
Axiome 1: zéro est un nombre.
Axiome 2: tout nombre possède un suivant.
Axiome 3: zéro n'est le suivant d'aucun nombre.
Axiome 4: Si deux nombres ont le même suivant, il sont égaux
etc...
Et puis, si vous voulez faire des maths plus compliqués
Eh bah, on se passe en général sur les axiomes de la théorie des ensembles,
qu'on appelle les axiomes ZFC
Le message important ici c'est que quand on dit qu'un truc est démontrable,
c'est jamais démontrable dans l'absolu,
c'est toujours sous entendu "en utilisant un certain système d'axiomes".
Par exemple, si je dit que j'arrive à démontrer qu'il y a une infinité de nombre premiers,
c'est probablement en utilisant les axiomes de Péano
en tout cas, certainement pas ceux d'Euclide.
Et si prend les axiomes de Péano et que j'en vire un ou deux,
bah il est vraisemblable que je n'arrive plus à démontrer qu'il y a une infinité de nombres premiers.
Vous comprenez bien pourquoi "vrai" et "démontrable" ce n'est pas la même chose.
Un truc vrai, c'est un truc vrai
et un truc démontrable, c'est toujours sous entendu en utilisant un certain système d'axiomes
et ca dépend du système d'axiomes qu'on utilise.
Au début du 20ème siècle, le mathématicien David Hilbert
s'est demandé si il existait un système d'axiomes parfait pour faire des maths.
Un système parfait, ca serait un système avec lequel absolument tout ce qui est vrai serait démontrable
et inversement, tout ce qui est faux serait réfutable.
Réfutable ca veut dire qu'on peut démontrer son contraire.
Un tel système, on appellerait ça un système complet.
Et vous voyez qu'à priori, c'est pas gagné. Si j'oublie un axiome,
je peux réduire considérablement le champ de ce qui est démontrable ou réfutable
un peu comme si j'oubliais d'inclure un type de brique de légo.
D'un autre coté, contrairement aux légos, avec les systèmes d'axiomes, il faut faire un petit peu attention.
On peut pas rajouter n'importe comment des axiomes à tout-va
parce qu'il y a un danger mortel qui nous guette:
qu'on se retrouve en situation de démontrer un truc, et son contraire.
J'vais reprendre mon exemple simpliste.
Si je ne fais pas gaffe et que j'ajoute deux axiomes
Axiome 4: Socrate est un philosophe
et axiome 5: Tous les philosophes sont immortels.
Bah vous voyez que j'ai un soucis. J'ai déjà montré que Socrate était mortel, c'était mon théorème,
mais là, en combinant le 4 et le 5 j'obtiens un nouveau théorème qui dit que Socrate est immortel.
Donc avec mon système d'axiome, j'arrive à démontrer un truc, et son contraire
Et en maths, on veut surtout pas ça
Arriver à démontrer un truc et son contraire, ce serait l'équivalent d'un cataclysme logique.
Un système d'axiomes qui évite cet écueil, on dit qu'il est cohérent.
Et donc voilà, l'idée de Hilbert de trouver un système d'axiomes parfait
c'était d'avoir un système d'axiomes qui soit à la fois complet, mais aussi bien sûr cohérent.
L'espoir de Hilbert c'était d'arriver à prouver qu'on était en train de bâtir les mathématiques sur un socle solide.
Eh bien c'est cet espoir que Gödel a torpillé.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Le premier théorème d'incomplétude de Gödel nous dit la chose suivante:
à partir du moment où on peut faire au moins de l'arithmétique, quel que soit le système d'axiomes qu'on utilise,
Il existera toujours des affirmations qui ne sont ni démontrables, ni réfutables.
Ces affirmations, on dit qu'elles sont indécidables.
Et pourtant, ces affirmations sont quand même soit vraies soit fausses
mais on peut pas le démontrer avec les axiomes.
Et donc, quelle que soit la manière dont on les choisisse,
nos systèmes d'axiomes seront toujours nécessairement incomplets.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on appelle ça le théorème d'incomplétude.
Si je reprend mon analogie légo,
ça revient à dire que quelles que soit les formes et les couleurs des briques de bases que je me donne,
il existera toujours des structures que j'arriverais pas à construire.
Mais ça veut dire quoi une affirmation arithmétique qui soit vraie mais indémontrable?
Bah je vous ai parlé dans une vidéo précédente de la conjecture de Goldbach,
celle qui dit que tout nombre pair à partir de 4, peut s'écrire comme somme de deux nombres premiers.
Bah on a cherché par ordinateur jusqu'à un milliard de milliard, et ça marche,
on n'a jamais trouvé de contre exemple, c'est donc que ça doit être vrai,
mais personne n'arrive à le démontrer,
Eh bien peut être que c'est vrai, mais indémontrable avec les axiomes qu'on utilise.
Peut être que la conjecture de Goldbach est indécidable dans notre système d'axiomes.
Et ce qui est fou, c'est qu'y'a aucun moyen de rafistoler notre système:
quelques soient les axiomes qu'on utilise, il existera toujours des propositions qui sont indécidables,
des sortes de zones d'ombre.
Et ça, ça montre que la méthode axiomatique, elle est intrinsèquement limitée,
même pour une chose aussi simple que l'arithmétique des nombres entiers.
Alors rassurez vous, des propositions qui soient à coup sûr indécidables
on en croise quand même pas tous les jours.
L'une d'elles, je l'avais évoquée dans ma vidéo sur l'infini.
C'est l'hypothèse du continu :
la question de savoir si il existe un infini plus grand que celui des nombres entiers,
mais plus petit que celui des nombres réels.
Et bien l'hypothèse du continu, c'est une proposition indécidable,
même avec les axiomes ZFC de la théorie des ensembles.
Maintenant que vous avez une idée de ce que raconte ce théorème, on va s'attarder un peu sur sa démonstration.
Ben oui, comment c'est possible de démontrer un truc pareil?
Evidemment je ne vais pas vous faire la démonstration en entier et en détail,
même si elle n'est pas si compliquée que ça une fois qu'on a pigé la philosophie générale.
Et justement, je voudrais vous donner un aperçu de cette philosophie.
Considérez l'affirmation suivante :
"Il existe une infinité de nombres premiers"
Cette affirmation, c'est une affirmation arithmétique qui porte sur les nombres entiers
et elle est soit vraie, soit fausse.
En l'occurrence elle est vraie.
Maintenant, considérer l'affirmation :
"La proposition "Il existe une infinité de nombres premiers" est démontrable"
Cette affirmation est vraie aussi, mais ce n'est pas une affirmation arithmétique,
elle ne porte pas sur les nombres entiers eux-mêmes, mais sur l'existence d'une démonstration.
On dit que c'est une affirmation méta-arithmétique.
La distinction est vraiment essentielle.
Quand je vous dis qu'un truc sur les nombres est vrai,
je fais une affirmation arithmétique.
Mais quand je dis que ce truc est démontrable,
je fais une affirmation méta-arithmétique.
Et c'est là que Gödel a trouvé un truc diabolique.
Quand je dis qu'un truc est démontrable, ça veut dire que je peut écrire une suite d'affirmations qui partent des axiomes
et qui les combinent pour arriver jusqu'à mon théorème.
Chacune de ces lignes, on pourrait l'écrire
avec des symboles mathématiques convenus d'avance
de manière à s'affranchir de la langue
et à tout écrire de manière formalisée comme une suite de formules.
Gödel a proposé d'associer un nombre à chaque symbole,
et de construire avec un nombre qui va représenter chaque formule de manière unique.
C'est une manière de coder des formules avec des nombres.
Et grâce à cette astuce, je peux finalement ramener toute ma démonstration, qui était une suite de formules,
à une suite de nombres qui s'enchaînent selon certaines règles.
Si ça vous intéresse, vous pouvez aller regarder ça un peu plus en détail, ça s'appelle le codage de Gödel.
Alors ça peut paraître complètement stupide comme idée,
parce qu'on part d'une démonstration avec des formules qui n'est déjà pas forcément hyper simple à comprendre,
et on ramène ça à une suite de nombres,
donc ça obscurcit complètement la démonstration, on ne pige plus rien.
Mais voilà à quoi ça va servir:
prenez une affirmation arithmétique, qu'on va appeler A.
Par exemple, "il existe une infinité de nombres premiers".
Dire que A est démontrable,
c'est la même chose de dire qu'il en existe une démonstration,
ce qui, grâce au codage de Gödel,
est la même chose que de dire qu'il existe une certaine suite de nombres,
qui s'enchaînent selon certaines règles et qui codent cette démonstration.
Et l'existence de cette suite de nombres, et bien ça c'est une affirmation arithmétique,
mais ce n'est pas la même que l'affirmation arithmétique A, mais on peut lui associer, on va l'appeler C(A).
Et pourquoi c'est génial?
Parce que d'un côté, on a une affirmation méta-arithmétique, de démontrabilité, un truc pas très palpable;
et qu'on arrive à lui associer une bonne vieille information arithmétique classique.
On dit parfois que Gödel a réussi a réussi à refléter la méta-arithmétique dans l'arithmétique.
Passons maintenant à la deuxième astuce qui permet de faire la démonstration du théorème de Gödel.
Vous connaissez le paradoxe du menteur?
Vous savez, l'histoire du menteur qui dit "je suis en train de vous mentir".
Sauf que si il vous ment c'est que finalement il est en train de dire la vérité,
et si il dit la vérité c'est qu'il vous ment, paradoxe.
Et bien Gödel s'est un peu inspiré de ça.
On l'a dit, grâce au codage, à toute affirmation arithmétique A,
on peut associer une affirmation codée C(A),
telle que A est démontable si et seulement si C(A) est vraie.
Et bien par un procédé astucieux que je vous épargne,
Gödel a montré qu'on pouvait toujours fabriquer une affirmation arithmétique en particulier,
on va l'appeler G en son honneur,
telle que C(G) soit le contraire de G, on l'appelle parfois non-G.
Cette affirmation G, on l'écrit pas explicitement, on sait qu'elle existe ça nous suffit,
et donc pour elle on a "G est démontrable si et seulement si non-G est vraie".
ou autrement dit, G est démontrable si et seulement si G est fausse.
Alors prenez une  bonne inspiration et examinez cette phrase deux minutes.
Vous voyez qu'on a deux cas de figure: soit G est fausse et démontrable,
soit, à l'inverse, G est vraie et indémontrable.
Alors on va commencer par le second cas : G est vraie et indémontrable.
Et bien voilà, on y est, c'est ce dont je vous parle depuis le début.
Si c'est vrai ça veut dire qu'on a réussi à construire une affirmation en particulier,
qui est à la fois vraie mais indémontrable et donc le système d'axiomes qu'on utilise est nécessairement incomplet.
Intuitivement, on pourrait essayer de sauver les meubles en disant bah cette proposition G qui est indémontrable,
j'ai qu'à la rajouter à mon système d'axiomes, comme ça je suis tranquille.
Et bien non parce que la construction de Gödel fonctionne quel que soit le système d'axiomes.
On pourra toujours recommencer ce petit jeu et construire une nouvelle proposition indécidable.
Même avec des systèmes d'axiomes aussi riches qu'on veut, il restera toujours des zones d'ombre.
Tout ça nous dit que le rêve de Hilbert de trouver un système d'axiomes parfait, et bien il est sans espoir.
Alors notez bien que ça ne nous empêche pas de faire des maths, mais parfois on peut se trouver dans des situations
où on soit obligé de passer dans un système d'axiomes plus puissant pour pouvoir démontrer des choses.
Prenons un exemple, vous connaissez certainement le théorème de Fermat,
celui qui dit que dès que n est plus grand que 3, il est impossible de trouver trois nombres entiers
tels que x puissance n plus y puissance n égal z puissance n.
Donc ça c'est une affirmation purement arithmétique.
Donc on aura envie de penser qu'on devrait pouvoir la démontrer
en utilisant juste les axiomes de l'arithmétique de Péano.
Et bien peut être que c'est possible, mais aujourd'hui la démonstration existante de Andrew Wiles,
utilise des maths bien plus sophistiqués que la simple arithmétique,
et donc se base sur les axiomes ZFC de la théories des ensembles.
Et en fait peut-être que Fermat est indémontrable si on se limite aux axiomes de Péano,
mais on sait pas.
Tout à l'heure je vous ai dit que Gödel avait réussi à démontrer qu'on pouvait toujours construire une proposition G,
telle que G soit démontrable si et seulement si elle est fausse.
Alors on a traité le premiers cas, celui ou G est vraie et indémontrable.
Mais qu'est-ce qu'il en est du deuxième, celui ou G est fausse et démontrable?
Et bien dans ce cas là c'est encore pire parce que ça veut dire que notre système d'axiomes
nous permet de démontrer des choses fausses et là c'est la catastrophe.
Tout ce qu'on a pu construire avec s'effondre. On dit que c'est un système incohérent.
En résumé, Gödel nous dit qu'à partir du moment où on fait au minimum de l'arithmétique,
quel que soit le système d'axiomes qu'on utilise, il est soit incomplet, soit incohérent.
C'est à dire qu'on à le choix entre la peste - et le choléra?
Bah non pas le choléra, mais disons entre la peste et le rhume.
Si notre système d'axiomes est incomplet c'est le rhume, si il est incohérent là c'est franchement la peste.
Alors rassurez-vous, si les axiomes qu'on utilise tous les jours pour faire des maths étaient incohérents,
on pense qu'on s'en serair rendu compte, on aurait déjà réussi à démontrer un truc et son contraire.
C'est par exemple ce qui c'étai passé avec les tous premiers axiomes de la théorie des ensembles.
Dans la théorie des ensembles naïves telle qu'elle avait été formulée au début et qu'on a depuis abandonnée,
on avait le droit de faire des ensembles de tout et n'importe quoi, et notamment des ensmbles d'ensemble.
Et on n'autorisait même qu'un ensemble puisse se contenir lui-même.
Et tout ça avait abouti à un paradoxe logique:
si un ensemble peut se contenir lui-même,
on peut définir l'ensemble des ensembles qui se contiennent eux-mêmes,
et à l'inverse, on peut parler de l'ensemble des ensembles qui ne se contiennent pas eux-mêmes.
Cet ensemble on va l'appeler E. Question : est-ce que E se contient lui-même?
Bah je vous laisse vous convaincre qu'il y a un paradoxe logique.
Si il se contient lui-même, alors il ne se contient pas lui-même. Et boum.
Depuis on a guéri les axiomes de la théorie des ensembles et le problème ne s'est plus jamais représenté.
On a de bonnes raisons de penser que s'il y avait une contradiction, on l'aurait trouvée rapidement.
N'empêche qu'on aimerait bien pouvoir être certains de ça.
Quand on voit un système d'axiomes, on voudrait être capable de dire si on est dans la situation rhume ou peste,
c'est à dire si il est incomplet ou incohérent.
En pratique ce qu'on aimerait surtout est capable de démontrer c'est qu'il n'est pas incohérent,
c'est à dire qu'il est incomplet mais c'est quand même moindre mal.
Et bah là, bam, Gödel a à nouveau torpillé cet espoir.
Gödel a démontré que la cohérence d'un système d'axiomes
faisait justement partie des propositions indécidables de ce système,
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas démontrer qu'un système d'axiomes est cohérent en restant à l'intérieur de ce système.
On appelle ça le second théorème d'incomplétude de Gödel.
Et il est évidemment essentiel même si on l'oublie parfois. Il a d'ailleurs fait très mal à Hilbert.
Résumons la situation:
le premier théorème d'incomplétude de Gödel nous dit que
tout système d'axiomes qu'on utilise pour faire au moins de l'arithmétique,
est soit incomplet soit incohérent.
Et le deuxième théorème nous dit que la cohérence ne peut pas être démontrée en restant à l'intérieur du système.
Alors en apparence le théorème de Gödel est catastrophique.
Il nous dit au mieux qu'il existera toujours des zones d'ombres,
c'est à dire des choses qui soient vraies mais qu'on arrivera jamais à démontrer avec les axiomes qu'on utilise,
et au pire que notre système est incohérent,
c'est à dire qu'on est peut-être en train de démontrer des trucs complètement faux, et qu'un jour tout va s'effondrer.
Alors ça c'est la théorie mais rassurez vous en pratique, le théorème de Gödel n'est pas bien grave.
Si vous êtes au lycée, n'allez pas voir le prof de maths en lui demandant
si il est certain que l'exo numéro 17 serait pas par hasard une proposition indécidable,
ou bien en suggérant que le système d'axiomes qu'on utilise est peut-être incohérent.
Non, on sait fabriquer explicitement des propositions indécidables,
mais elles sont déjà assez sophistiquées et puis il n'y en a pas légion.
Et généralement on s'en sort en utilisant un système d'axiomes plus fort.
Par exemple en utilisant les axiomes de ZFC, au lieu des axiomes de l'arithmétique de Péano.
L'intérêt du théorème de Gödel il est surtout conceptuel, philosophique,
mais en pratique il n'empêche pas les mathématiciens de dormir.
Alors il faut quand même dire un truc, ce théorème il a été beaucoup abusé et déformé,
pour lui faire dire tout et n'importe quoi.
Des choses du genre "rien n'est certain", "la connaissance humaine est à jamais limitée",
ou bien "les maths ne nous disent rien de connaissable avec certitide".
Non, retenez que le théorème de Gödel s'applique dans un cadre très précis:
les systèmes d'axiomes, et je devrais ajouter récursifs, qui contiennent au moins l'arithmétique.
Donc ne faites pas dire à Gödel ce qu'il n'a pas dit.
Sur un sujet comme celui-ci, il y a évidemment plus que jamais plein de choses que j'aurais pu raconter en plus,
pour préciser des trucs un peu flous voire même carrément un peu faux que j'ai dit.
Par exemple ça: "Un truc vrai, c'est un truc vrai".
Ou bien encore ça : "Même avec des systèmes d'axiomes aussi riches qu'on veut".
Si ces questions vous intéressent, j'en parle dans le billet qui accompagne la vidéo,
et qui vous parle notamment de la théorie des modèles, ou du théorème de complétude de Gödel,
qu'il a démontré pendant sa thèse, avant de démontrer ses théorèmes d'incomplétude.
Autre aspect que j'ai également passé sous silence,
on peut avoir sur le théorème de Gödel un regard beaucoup plus alogorithmique,
plus proche de ce que font les gens qui font de l'informatique théorique par exemple.
Alors j'ai choisi de ne pas prendre cette présentation
mais Thomas de la chaîne Passe-science a fait une vidéo très bien sur le sujet que je vous encourage à aller voir.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo!
Si elle vous a pu n'hésitez pas à la liker, à la partager, à vous abonner.
Vous pouvez suivre les actualités de la chaîne sur Facebook et sur Twitter,
et vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur Tipee, un grand merci à tous les tiper qui me soutiennent.
A bientôt!